One, two, three.
Hit it!
Hey. Yo.
Ruff. Ruff.
Oh wrong show.
I’m so sorry.
My Dad the Bounty Hunter
is a sci-fi animated series
that takes place in outer space
that centers around
a beautiful black family.
Dad's really leaning
into the divorce guy thing.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
No, we're not divorced.
We're just separated.
So it’s real life.
Y’all getting real life
black animation up in here.
-Suprise!
Huh?
In the series, Lisa
and her brother go on this
intergalactic journey
to find out that
their dad is a bounty
hunter.
That...
was so awesome!
When you hit the one guy
with the other guy.
Whuh. Whuh. Aaaahhh!
Your mom's gonna kill me.
I feel like there's
so many surprises and twists
and turns in this story.
When you watch it, you're
going to be mind blown.
Woah.
Wait. Where are my
warp pods?
Warp pods?
My warp pods.
Small, blue orbs about
this big.
There was a bunch in a
silver briefcase back here.
Oh, warp pods.
Yeah, we threw those out.
You what?
There wasn't enough room
for us in the trunk.
Were they important
or something?
Yes! The ship needs them
to make warp jumps.
We are light
years from home!
Can't you just buy more?
Can I just buy more?
You got warp pod
money on you?
Do you know how much
them things cost?
-Like twenty bucks?
-Or three dollars?
Not only will
this animation be for like
younger kids to watch,
but also for adults
in the family show as well
because everyone
can kind of relate to it.